do you think bin laden is evil oh yeah
yeah i mean he was a mass murderer um
i'm just saying that you know his ideas
were
they're more complex than than we've
tended to acknowledge
um they had
they have a wider potential resonance
than we would acknowledge i mean and
also i guess what i'm the just
one fundamental point is that
um
thinking about the complexity of bin
laden is also a way of
removing him from islam
he is not an islamic thinker he is a
cosmopolitan thinker who
plays in all kinds of modern ideologies
which have proven to mobilize people in
the past right so um you know
anti-semitism
um populism environmentalism and the
kind of in the the urging to like
you know do something about humanity do
something about suffering that's why i
think the actual you ask about like what
motivates people to do this kind of
stuff i think that's why if one goes
below the level of leadership
and this is being reported if you look
at the
trial ongoing now in paris of
uh the bataclan
murders i think um
the court allowed some discussion of the
backgrounds of the accused and they come
from
different backgrounds but if there's any
common bond it's kind of that they
had some background in petty crime
famously in the 7-7 bombings in london
the
metropolitan police you know uk
authorities looked at all those guys
and
what people want is this idea that like
they must be very pious they must be you
know super islamic to do this kind of
stuff
they must be fanatical true believers
but
what they found with those guys was that
some were
nominally muslim
some went to mosques some didn't
some were single young guys with like
criminal backgrounds
some
you know we're like sorry they were
you know kind of misfits who never
succeeded anything
uh but others had you know at least one
thing had a wife and family who he you
know widowed and orphaned and so there's
no i mean for policing i mean if you're
looking at that lens
there is no kind of typology that will
predict
who will become violent that's why i
think we have to move beyond thinking
about religious augmentation narrowly or
by itself
and think about things like geopolitics
think about
how people respond to inequality
you know the the existential threat of
cri of a you know climate crisis
of um a whole host of matters of and and
think about th this is a mode of
political contestation i mean it's a
violent one it's one i condemn it is
evil right
but these are people that are they're
trying to be political they're trying to
change things in some way
it's not nearly about like i want to
impose sharia law on you
you must wear a veil
you must eat this kind of food it's it's
not that parochial
you